if you're familiar with the scp
foundation then you already know the
exact reason why there are multiple
scp-001s you may even think you know
which of them is the real scp-001
but for those of you who are new here or
who just need a little reminder the
designation of
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies that are
apparently kept in containment by the
scp foundation at present it is unclear
why there are multiple files collected
under the shared designation of scp-001
some believe it is because these
anomalies are some of the earliest ever
contained by the foundation
this would mean that they share the
designation of scp-001
as they were likely encountered before
the scp foundation introduced their
current numbering system however there
also exists a theory that this is
nothing more than intentional
misdirection perhaps the multiple
scp-001 files are an attempt by the
foundation to conceal information about
the true scp-001
after all it wouldn't be the first time
this hyper-secretive organization
deceived us anomalies sharing the name
scp-001 include the infamous scarlet
king the massive gate guardian and the
world ending event known as when
daybreaks but today we'll be using
scp-001 to refer not to an entity or an
event but to a location a location
codenamed god's blind spot located in an
unassuming corner of the world is a site
that the scp foundation constructed and
designated as facility tea
according to their archive it's a
largely unremarkable place situated at a
spot on the sinai peninsula which is a
part of egypt that forms a bridge
between the continents of africa and
asia in the 18th century archaeologists
excavating the area uncovered the
remains of a stone structure believed to
be an inn that dates back to the second
millennium bc however since the
construction of facility t
any trace of this structure has since
disappeared so what makes this
unremarkable site so important to the
scp foundation
why establish a facility if there was
nothing anomalous about its nature what
distinguishes this
scp-001 site in the eyes of the
foundation is the area's profound lack
of any ambient akiva radiation but what
is akiva radiation well according to the
foundation's researchers it's a form of
cosmic background radiation one that's
not overtly harmful to human beings if
you grew up in a strict church-going
household then it's highly likely you
would have been exposed to a lot of this
non-electromagnetic radiation and never
even realized it you see the thing with
akiva radiation is that it is directly
correlated with the amount of religious
faith a person has regardless of which
religion someone follows akiva radiation
will form around them it tends to be
harmless to humans however certain
anomalous entities in scps considered to
be demonic in nature can be repelled and
even fought off with high levels of
akiva radiation the presence of other
powerful anomalies those considered more
benign or even holy can also create an
increase in this radiation
scp-001 has earned the nickname god's
blind spot for a number of reasons one
being that it is the only place on earth
with the natural absence of this akiva
radiation the foundation has conducted
experiments that involved bringing
sources known to emit akiva radiation
into the area of
scp-001 but when they measured no change
in radiation levels was detected meaning
that the space around facility t does
not actively block akiva radiation from
entering it but also cannot absorb or
retain this religious radiation it might
be more accurate to say that the
location destroys any trace of residual
akiva without damaging the source a lack
of faith-filled radiation is far from
the only anomalous property of scp-001
though during a number of tests
involving d-class personnel the
foundation witnessed that while in the
area it also becomes impossible for the
death of any human being to occur a
discovery that obviously needed to be
researched further the first test
involved a healthy human male who was
left in a containment cell on the
scp-001 site and observed he had no
supplies no food no water yet over 120
days this man stayed alive never
succumbing to starvation or dehydration
next a female member of d-class was
exposed to a lethal dose of cyanide gas
within facility t and suffered none of
the expected effects foundation
researchers then repeated this cyanide
gas test using 30 common brown rats all
of which were killed proving that it was
only humans that couldn't be killed
while within
scp-001 god's blind spot seems to also
be able to slow or halt the effects of
terminal illnesses as proven when a
d-class with stage 4 cancer was brought
into scp-001
despite her prognosis stating that she
would be dead imminently the woman
survived in the area for almost 800 days
her cancer symptoms never advanced and
she only died after finally leaving the
area of
scp-001 there are limitations to this
anomalous effect though one test
involved cremating a healthy male
d-class while he was still alive the
man's body caught fire just as you would
expect it to and he was burned to death
according to the findings of that test
and similar variations foundation
researchers have learned that the
life-preserving qualities of scp-001
don't prevent death by extreme external
damage one of the final tests to take
place within scp-001
involved a pair of 24 year old identical
d-class twins one of the twins
designated twin a was held at facility t
while the other twin b was imprisoned in
a cell at a different foundation site
after observing them for over 26 years
twin b aged naturally to the age of 50.
his twin however did not appear to age
at all over the course of two and a half
decades it was only when moved to
another facility that twin a began to
show signs of aging the aging process
for twin a was rapid too and eventually
he caught up with his brother being a
benign non-threatening anomaly the
foundation has been more than happy to
use god's blind spot to their own
advantage facility t was specifically
established on this site to house the
headquarters of the o5 council the
overseers of the entire scp foundation
it's hardly surprising that the overseer
council would want to set up shop here
after all it's the one spot on planet
earth where no human being can ever die
of natural causes and will not age for
the duration of their stay
of course this locked the o5 council to
one location but what if they could
replicate the effects of scp-001
elsewhere of course this is what the scp
foundation attempted following their
research into god's blind spot the
foundation's own dr marvin scranton
attempted to artificially recreate the
area's anomalous effects somewhere else
his hope was by generating a vacuum of
akiva radiation that a second instance
of
scp-001 would occur at a location of his
choosing or as his assistant beartrend
put it they planned to build a box and
then push god out of it as it turned out
god had other plans dr scranton quickly
realized the hubris of his scheme the
akiva radiation in the selected area
rapidly dropped to zero just as planned
but then something unexpected happened
scranton detected an increase in humes
these are essentially parts of the
fabric of reality and are what's often
disrupted by reality bending as cps
something had come into our world thanks
to the o5 council's attempt to recreate
scp-008
something impossible for the foundation
to measure or observe in other words
scranton had no idea what he unleashed
or where it went following this incident
the o5 council realized a worrying
increase in the anomalous incidents they
were encountering whether or not this
came as a direct result of their
meddling with the fabric of the universe
was unclear but it forced the council to
reconsider the focus and direction of
the entire scp foundation up until this
point they had been an organization
focused purely on research but now they
had to embrace a new approach to how
they handled anomalies from then on the
foundation's objective became to
actively seek out and contain anomalous
entities creatures objects and locations
like scp-001
rather than just observing these
phenomena for study they would secure
contain and protect the final portion of
scp-001's file is a memorandum detailing
an arrangement between the o5 council
and an unknown counterparty in the
document someone named sheldon katz set
out revised terms for the foundation's
continued use of facility t sheldon
states that he has reached an
understanding with the counterparty and
that the contents of the document are to
serve as a formal agreement a contract
of sorts between the scp foundation and
someone else according to this contract
the incident with scranton put a strain
on the relationship between the
foundation and whoever the counterparty
is and that the 05 council are seeking
to make amends in order to continue
their new goal of collecting and
containing anomalies so who was this
counterparty that the overseer council
was so desperate to appease and have on
their side who could possibly be a
higher power than the most powerful
secret organization on earth well an
actual higher power of course that's
right the o5 council was making a deal
with god over how they were allowed to
use his blind spot or at least a very
powerful being that considers itself to
be god the rules laid out on their
agreement stated that no person was
permitted to stay at the site of scp-001
for more than 120 years including
members of the o5 council along with
other members of foundation staff
management researchers security
personnel and test subjects additionally
the scp foundation's ethics committee
was required to annually report any and
all of the o5 council's decisions to god
for his own part god was restricted from
smiting or exacting his terrible wrath
upon any member of foundation personnel
that's right a perk of working for the
scp foundation is getting
around-the-clock divine protection at
least from god himself that's still a
lot better than an employee dental plan
this came with a condition however that
anyone committing a transgression or
mortal sin was given a 90-day written
notice and an opportunity to repent
their wrong doing in return god demanded
that members of the foundation only
worshipped him and no other divine
entities i the lord am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
was written in the contract finally the
agreement between the 05 council and god
was that they would work together the
foundation and the counterparty would be
equal partners when it came to the
containment of scps and anomalies of all
the strange and unexplained phenomena
that the scp foundation encounters on a
regular basis it hardly comes as much of
a surprise that they've got a direct
line to the big guy upstairs or at least
one who purports to be still the fact
that the o5 council have a business
arrangement with an ultra powerful deity
like being and express written
permission to use his blind spot where
no person can die or age is hardly a
comforting thought at least the scp
foundation only ever uses its power for
good right now go check out
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one
and
scp-001 when day daybreaks for more
scp-001 action